um good afternoon Mr mcgrade
um you're here to interview for the
civilian I.T software positions that is
that right yes
excellent we've seen your CV very
impressive worked at MIT or studied at
MIT and worked at Google and Microsoft
in the last few years so I apologize by
the way that we've had to do the
interview
um this way we've got a little bit of a
nanovirus situation at the base and
nobody in Iraq for a few days I'm afraid
um so we'll just get straight into the
interviews if that's okay so we've got a
few questions for you a few scenario
questions
um the other team leaders from the base
have put forward I I appreciate you
don't know a lot about the role
um but I apprecially you understand that
we can only share so much information
until the role is offered is that okay
yeah I I know it's just based on
stipulations at the moment excellent
okay so the first question obviously
it's one of those interview questions
you have to ask but um what are your
strengths and weaknesses that you think
would make you ideal for this kind of
role well like you said I I went to MIT
I've I've studied a lot within computer
science and things of the sort so I
think I can bring a lot to the
technology role to the program and what
I don't know I'm I'm a quick learner so
I'd love to pick up everything that they
have
how do you feel about any situations
where you think you might have to think
outside of the box are you a bigger
thinker or do you prefer
methodical thinking I like methodical
thinking and I respect it but I can
think outside of the box when necessary
I think
how that might come up occasionally so
why do you want to work for the SGC
well
obviously it's this new government
program that's been kind of around for
who knows how long but it's it's been
public I guess at least for a little
while and it seems like this new fun
program to work for nobody wants to work
for the FBI or CIA or NSA anymore the
SGC sounds fun
it's definitely that but are you
absolutely certain you want to work for
the SGC
hey I'm a fan of Colorado and I can help
in tech support no matter what so I'm
yeah I think I think so I think so yeah
absolutely certain right you sure yes
okay
have you or any of your family ever
suffered from only heart conditions
I'm not that I'm aware of no
okay so you wouldn't have any proper
like high pressure rolls that wouldn't
be a problem
I don't think so so we have all had
appendectomies by 25 though
okay that sounds fun well that I'm sure
that won't be a problem but but high
stress scenarios fighting for your life
that sort of thing that you you don't
have any concerns
oh
what kind of scenario are we talking
now just those normal sort of you know
something weird happens all of a sudden
you are battling Against All Odds to
protect yourself and others
that sort of thing
I'll give it my best shot
excellent okay generally in these
scenarios
um we just think using some sort of
weapon is probably the best bet and just
um yeah just just keep fighting until
the last man's life that sort of thing
so this role requires an open-minded
approach can you give me an example of a
time when you have had to approach a
problem with an open mind
oh well that I was hired by Microsoft
whenever I I was working there when they
introduced Windows Quantum 15 and that's
when they integrated Quantum Computing
into windows and
that was a doozy you could say the least
so we had to keep an open mind while
things were not going right there and uh
figured it out slowly but surely but we
had to keep an open mind there were a
lot of problems coming in and you know
we tackled them one step at a time and
we managed it
so just give me so I can throw out a few
examples let's say maybe I don't know
say you found out tomorrow that aliens
are actually real and been visiting the
Earth would that is that the sort of
thing that might phase you or would you
be able to take that in your stride
um I'd like to take it in stride I think
um you know being just a computer in
science
being just a computer in science geek
it's just a fun thing to think about
aliens I've always wanted them to be
real maybe they are
sure I'd say sure
have you ever seen a UFO or anything you
can't explain
I've seen some weird lights before that
that have done a couple weird things but
that that could be some college days in
the desert as well so I'm not sure
How about if one of those weird lights
came down actually somebody came out a
little gray fella shook your hand and
said hello I'm uh I don't know and ask
God you know something
like like Odin or Thor or something I
like that
oh uh I mean I don't know I don't I
don't think aliens are going to be the
little green or gray people with big
eyes and smooth heads that's
there's no way so well yeah you'll
you'll you'll be surprised so um do you
have any fears or phobias we need to
know about for example I mean like how
are you with spiders
oh I'm fine with spiders uh how about
massive little spiders
metal spiders actually robots are
something that I'm not the biggest fan
of because I I make them they scare me
sometimes so robot spiders may do it for
me actually that might scare me a bit
okay
well good luck if you're successful so
we've got a couple of scenario questions
for you um this first one has been put
forward by our health and safety
um representative
so it's just you know just out of the
box you know just just these little
scenarios you just give me your best
answer don't think about it too much
just an honest answer
so you are in an unknown location you
see a strange light coming from the wall
do you a investigate but from a safe
distance
document what you've seen but do not
approach
or stick your head in it and just see
what happens
well being the I.T guy I would say that
you should investigate from a safe
distance
okay so don't just stick your head in
and hope for the best
uh leave that to the military
okay good good answer good answer I
think not the health safety guy will be
very pleased with that so there is a
military threat
you have to act without considering the
logistics of the operation would you a
attempt to minimize collateral damage B
use the maximum Force at your disposal
or blow up the nearest star and hope for
the best
could you repeat the last one and blow
this down hope for the best
and you'd be surprised how often that
option seems to be the only one I think
I'm gonna go with option A
okay
so you just attempt to minimize
collateral damage can you elaborate on
that a little bit and just say why you
would go for that scenario and well I
guess coming from my perspective from
the computer I I would I always try to
minimalize damage just keep keep the
programs we put into effect and check
right
okay
why why not I mean again I say you'd be
surprised how often
option C comes up but you know
minimize collateral damage I'm all with
you on that so just uh one more scenario
question so um you meet a person and
they say that they are a God would you a
discuss their beliefs and consider the
possibility of a higher being
B be skeptical but respect their belief
structure or see arm their followers and
inspire a resistance
um
I I think I would go with b
um be very skeptical about it
um
I I think mathematics are a god
obviously through through Computing
Computing through Computing
um I'm not sure about a person claiming
to be a God I would be skeptical that is
for sure
and you're absolutely certain you
wouldn't heavily arm all their followers
and try and Inspire an armed resistance
I don't think we should do that anywhere
here on this planet
really
okay
crazy well finally we've got one last
question for you and this is obviously
probably the most important question
so you have a colleague Who's acting
strangely
do you ignore it they're probably just
stressed report the behavior too
Superior or shoot first burn the body
and figure it all out later
I love what you're doing on the sea see
answers in these
um I think
I'd probably
depending on how severely
the other person's acting
either A or B probably B then a or a
then B just depending on the scenario
just report the behavior to don't don't
shoot first I I tend to not do
as a a piece of family advice obviously
if you are successful in the role I
would consider c a little bit more often
just because again you'd be surprised
how often it comes up
just you know
okay mindless violence never hurt
anybody
just in case so
um those are all the questions that I I
have for you today Mr McGray do you have
any questions for me while you
um while we have this time
um
I don't I don't believe so it just seems
like such a fun work environment I'm
really excited for this opportunity
um I I I like all the questions you
asked if if people are this fun From The
Bottom Rung to the top wrong I think
it'll be a good good place to work you
thought the questions were fun
yeah all your joke joke little answers
in there they're great
but I've got what jokes sorry I like the
sons and the gods and the explosions and
that and the the shooting first and all
that kind of stuff
ah
okay
um
well yeah I'm sure yeah I'm sure it was
just let's go with it to his joke
in case you're unsuccessful let's go
pretend it was a joke
it's oh we're trying to have a lot of
fun here wait till the annual picnic
you'll you'll have a hoot it's it's
great the annual work picnic it's it's
brilliant
um can I just I'm just gonna end the
interview by just saying please don't
repeat anything that we have said here
today
um by accepting the interview you um
have unfortunately met all the criteria
for the stake Secrets act and if you do
repeat it you will be in prison for the
rest of your life
okay
sure okay thank you great somebody from
the HR department will be interested to
you in the next few days
thanks
[Music]